So with Aisha, it's well documented.
There's no one who denies that Aisha was
nine. In fact, there have been several
Muslims who've written responses
refuting the attempt by modern Muslims
to deny the age of Aisha. I'm going to
see if I can find. In fact, it's uh on I
think I've uploaded it to this blog. I
had it on my blog. They deleted my blog,
but I this brother pray for Isaac. He's
a good brother. He's uploaded all the
material here. Glory to Jesus Christ.
Aisha's age
revisiting the age of Aisha.
Two different Muslims. One Jabrel Fuad
Hadat who's a Sufi and another Salafi
destroy the objections raised by Muslims
that she was older saying it's a lie. So
just go to the blog here. Here this is
the one. Was Aisha really only nine?
Part four. So I uploaded here and here
it is. Salafi defense of M's marriage to
a minor part two and part one. So there
it is. These are by two Muslims
destroying the weak argument saying well
if you calculate the time that Aisha
said her sister's age and blah blah blah
blah they go that's a lie. That's not at
all the case. And they're defending that
she was nine. In point of fact in one of
my older articles here's what Iben Kir
says.
So go to the blog put in Aisha
nine right age put Aisha age and you get
the two Muslims destroying the
objections by other Muslims saying stop
it. Even Yaser Kari did a session he
said I've heard the attempts by Muslims
to try to show that she wasn't nine.
They're weak. I'm not convinced. Let us
not be ashamed that our sources teach
she was nine. Here's what Iben Kir
stated. I may have to do a series on
refuting their objections. Here's what
Iben Cathir said. Okay, I'm going to
give you the link to this article, but
go to the blog, put in Aisha age, find
where it says a celi defense of Aisha's
age as well as jabriel had. Okay, now
watch here.
>> It's there. That's I mean, come on. In
fact, you ask them up until modern
times, up until modern times, do you
know of any Muslim source that denied
she was nine? No.
Doesn't exist. It's only in the 20th
century, 21st century, they had to deny
it because now it's become a source of
embarrassment. So, I'm going to send
this to you in private chat right here.
And you go to answering Islam.blog.
Type in Aisha and age and read through
that the Muslims say, not what
Christians are saying, telling these
Muslims, stop with your lies and your
nonsense.
Okay. Now, here's what Iben Cathir says
about the age. Ib Kir is writing 700
years after the death of Muhammad. Let
me read what he says. Ready? This is one
of my older articles. Ununice bin buker
stated from Hashemwa. They'll say well
later on his memory was weak. They go
yes but earlier it wasn't. And they took
hadith from him and it's not just
Hashem. Others also narrated that she
was nine. So they destroy these
objections. The messenger of God married
Aisha 3 years after the death of
Khadijah. At that time of the contract,
Aisha had been a girl of six. When he
married her, she was nine. The messenger
of God died when Aisha was a girl of 18.
This tradition is considered unique. Al
Bkari related from bin is from Abuama
from Hisham bin Urwa from his father
said Khadijah died three years before
the immigration of the prophet Salah
dressing be upon him. He allowed a
couple of years or so to pass after
that. Then he contracted marriage with
Aisha when she was six. Thereafter
consummating the marriage with her when
she was 9 years old. Now watch what he's
going to say in a minute. This mosquito
is
>> Oh my god.
>> What UA stated here is Mul incomplete as
we mentioned above but in its content it
must be judges mutil uninterrupted.
His statement he contract contracted
marriage with Aisha when she was six.
book 700 years after death of Muhammad
thereafter consummate marriage with her
when she was nine is not disputed by
anyone and he wrote this 700 years after
death of Muhammad around the 14th 15th
centuries 15th centuries
why is it now disputed
>> because people are ashamed of it they're
discussing
>> precisely so let me finish what he says
and he's not the only one I quote a slew
I quote
You go right.
>> Those are uh those are inki.
So bkari didn't know later on had a weak
memory. Here I quote sunba
muslim bkari. I mean how many sources?
>> But now let me finish what he says here.
>> He consummated marriage. Notice not
disputed anyone. and is well established
in the Sah collections of traditions
elsewhere. 700 years after Muhammad, Ibn
Kir says no one disputes this.
He consummated marriage with her during
the second year following the
immigration of Medina. His contracting
marriage with her took place some 3
years after Khadijah's death that there
is disagreement over this when exactly
he married her not the age. The husband
stated al related to us that related to
him. This is the chain by the way from
binwa from his fatherwisha
who said the messenger contract marriage
with me after khadijah's death and
before his immigration from Mecca when I
was 6 years old after we arrived in
Medina. Some woman came to me while I
was playing on a swing. Look how young
she was. She used to play on swings.
My hair was like that of a boy. They
dressed me up because her hair had
fallen out and put makeup on me then
took me to the messenger of God and he
consummated our marriage when I was a
girl of nine and she was playing on
swings. And then it says she had her
dolls with her which is important
because according to [clears throat] man
>> yeah according to Islamic tradition uh
once you hit puberty you're not allowed
to play with the images or
>> doll the person oh
commenting on this saying because by the
way you guys if you don't know the
tradition he just mentioned it when you
are of age you cannot have images so you
can't have dolls
Why was Aisha allowed to play with
dolls? Because they said an allowance
was made for her because she was
prepubescent a premature minor and when
you're a preubescent premature minor you
can play with dolls until you reach
puberty. So Iban Haj alsani which I
quote here says that because of this it
is argued that Aisha did not reach
puberty until she was 14 at at around
I'm not going to say tabuka. and I want
to show it to you right now. So, not
only was Aisha playing with dolls
because she was a premature
preubescent minor. Images are not
allowed but only for minors. It says
that she reached puberty around the age
of 14.
>> Yeah, that's that's wild man. That's
you know who IBani is? He wrote Fatali
the commentary.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And I know I noticed that Aisha
were uh wrote some of that or just Aisha
sorry wrote some of that as well which
is crazy. And it's sad because in
Islamic tradition uh any of the prophet
Muhammad's wives uh couldn't remarry.
>> Exactly. So you left all his wives were
in their 20s except Aisha was 18. Even
Safia whose Jewish husband was tortured
and murdered and her Jewish tribe
exterminated when Muhammad went to marry
her. This is in the tradition. It says
he gave
seven slaves to have her. So much for
Islam abolishing slavery. I'll give you
the hadith. I'll show it to you. It says
he told here's seven slaves. Let me have
her because she was the wife of a
chieftain. And then he says, "If you
marry me, that will be your
emancipation. I will emancipate you if
you marry me." He left her. She was 17,
a wood in her 20s. None of them had
children. None of them could marry. None
of them have children till they died.
And he's a mercy on unto mankind or a
cancer.
>> That's crazy.
>> Now, let me finish this one part. The
statement here.
Notice guys, the word that's in chapter
3:55.
I will cause you to die. Isa, that's the
word used for death.
I thought doesn't mean die, you liars.
And the statement here's
death has to mean that it was shortly
thereafter, unless that is the word or
after originally preceded this phrase
and had been omitted from the account.
So anyway, where does this come from?
Also by Ibn Kir translated in English
volume 2 pages 9394 comes from his workh
okay is he the only one Ibenim Ibim
sorry of our time okayb and kir were
both the pupils of Ibia
does he say that Aisha was nine yeah
when she was six and consummated
marriage in the first year of the hij
and the month of sha
when she was nine
and this is inadb
700 years after Muhammad's death the two
star pupils of ibia and on and on it
goes brother
so why are they lying to you
I just uh I feel really guilty that uh I
left Jesus
Exactly
>> for this dog who's burning.
>> I caused I caused people to follow him,
too, which is I'm never going to talk to
them again. I don't have their contact
information to say I'm sorry.
>> Yep. Well, you know, God knew in your
ignorance, you didn't know any better.
But here, I'm going to show you
something. What did I Haj say? All
right, Aisha Dolls, watch here. You
ready?
>> Yeah. All right, you ready now? I think
it's this article here
or is it this one here?
Let me enlarge you here and uh I believe
it is seeben Haj and then we'll go into
the other topics guys or I'll get to
John one. I'll retitle this as well.
Okay.
All right. Here you go. This comes from
I took a long
Well, this is I don't know if I'm
quoting him, but I'll get it for you.
Alfb said in
this hadith is taken as evidence that it
is permissible to have dolls and toys
for girls to play with. This is an
exception to the permission of images.
This was stated by and it was narrated
from the majority that they allowed the
sale of toys and dolls so that girls
might learn from a young age how to take
care of their houses and their children.
I'm going to get you the actual quote.
So, it's from it's in the other one. Let
me go right here where I actually quote
him at length. So, it's this one here.
Muhammad's marriage and his moral
implications. Let's go here. I'll get
you the link to this. So, all you do is
put Aisha age and Iban Haj.
All right.
Okay. Here you go. This is it at length.
You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> You ready? Now, I'm going to shock you.
Bear with me guys. I'm going to read
what Iben Haj alsani said. Why was Aisha
allowed to play with dolls and he's
going to calculate she did not reach
puberty until she was 14. She did not
reach puberty until she was 14. Which
means from 9 to 14, Muhammad was
mounting a premature preubescent minor
playing with dolls.
A little girl. Okay. So, let's begin.
I had to refute a Muslim who lied about
Iban Haj
fati volume 13 page 143. You guys know
the Arabic. Go find it. You'll read it.
It's in his Arabic.
He states, "The reason why Aisha was
even allowed to play with dolls is
because she hadn't reached puberty." So,
I'm giving you the context by reading
the paragraph. This seeming
contradiction is easily resolved when
realized that Alcalani
is see now there's a typo here. Damn.
Sorry. comments were not made in regard
to age Aisha's age or maturity at the
time of marriage. They referred to the
specific hadith narrated Aisha
the mother believers when the apostle of
Allah arrived after the expect
expedition to tabuk see I didn't want to
say taboo I wanted to be careful because
it's either tabuk or kibbar
the narrator's doubtful the drought
raised an end of a curtain which was
hung in front of her storoom revealing
some dolls which belong to her now
notice guys what it's After
Muhammad's expedition against or
Aisha was playing with dolls well at
that time she was 13 close to 14. He
asked what is this? Muhammad is asking
her. She replied my dolls. Among them he
saw a horse with the wings made of rags
and asked what is this? I see among
them. She replied a horse. He asked what
is this that it has on it? She replied
two wings. He asked a horse with two
wings. She replied, "Have you not heard
that Solomon had horses with wings?" She
said, "There upon the Apostle Allah,
haha," laughed so hardly, "Haha, as he's
mounting the minor that I could see his
mer."
Now, what does Haj alsani say about
Aisha, her age at the time of the
expedition and playing with dolls? Here
you go. Alaf goes on to say, "Abu and
have narrated with another chain
from Aisha that she said the messenger
returns to the B of he mentioned the
hadith about his tearing down the
curtain which she attached to her ador
she said
then the side of the curtain which was
over the dolls of Aisha
was uncovered he toa peace be upon him
salad dressing what is this so he quotes
the hadith ali said from this hadith it
is understood that playing with dolls is
not like the amusement from other images
concerning which the threat of
punishment is mentioned. The only reason
why now notice she's around 14 at this
time. The only reason why permission and
this was given to Aisha is because she
had not at that time reached the age of
puberty.
Even at the time of the expedition
years after he married her she still
hadn't reached puberty. Al says, "I say
to say with certainty that she was not
yet at the age of 10 is questionable,
though it might possibly be so." This is
because Aisha was a 14year-old girl at
the time of the battle of Kaibar.
But when you reach puberty, you can't
play with dolls. So she's 14 and playing
with dolls. Either exactly 14 years old
or having just passed her 14th year and
entering into the 15th year or
approaching it. As for age, at the time
of the battle of Taboo, she had by then
definitely reached the age of puberty.
Therefore, the strongest view is that of
those who said it was in when she was
not yet at the age of puberty. Did you
catch it?
>> What did I said?
>> The strongest view it was
because she was 14 and still not reached
puberty. But by taboo, she reached
puberty. She couldn't play with dolls.
Did you hear it?
Yeah.
>> Do you understand what he's saying?
Right. Haj alsani
Haj alsani is saying the strongest view
is that this event took place at Kaibar
because she was 14 and hadn't reached
puberty yet which is why she was playing
with dolls. It couldn't be Tabuk which
was later because at that time she had
reached puberty and would not have
allowed to be playing with dolls.
That's crazy.
>> So why are they lying to you when they
tell you
that she wasn't nine and she was already
pubescent? Here you're told from 9 to 14
she was not pubescent which is why Allah
allowed her to play with dolls. So let
me finish it. and made reconciliation
between the apparent contradicting
rulings a permissive permissibility of
dolls in particular provision of images
in general with what alabi said this
this damn mosquito from Muhammad's ja
ali said that images are prohibited
except in the case of dolls for young
girls this because to reconcile is
better than assume the aid to be in
contradiction here binbaz concludes his
quotation from alafis
So now binbas is commenting because the
source is quoting Haj and then binbas's
ruling. The above is the essence of the
words of alafb
the beneficial response concerning
Islamic ruling pictures and images
Abdulazizb Abdullah binbas. So he's
commenting on ibar and he's saying this
is the ruling. She only reached puberty
when she was 14. And up until 14, she
was allowed to play with dolls, which is
why she hadn't been pubescent, which is
why she played with dolls.
>> That's crazy. See, I I br I brought some
of this stuff up to my imam and she
whenever I was practicing, and they
would never give me a clear answer, and
they would just say, "Oh, just focus on
the dean and your da. Power.